vamos a resolver este ejercicio que se
ve bastante divertido dice empareja
estos ángulos con sus medidas debe haber
un ángulo en cada categoría las
categorías son 30 60 90 y 135 grados
bueno al parecer puedo mover estas cajas
entonces hay algunos que son muy obvios
por ejemplo este ángulo que es recto
claramente es el de 90 grados y este
ángulo es el único que es d es mayor a
90 grados es obtuso entonces debe quedar
en la categoría de 135 grados vamos a
ver qué sucede con los otros dos
este es más pequeño que este así que
este debe ser el de 30 grados y este el
de 60 grados pero además tiene sentido
porque este es aproximadamente un sexto
de la circunferencia entonces por eso
sería de 60 grados y este es como un
doceavo vamos a ponerlos donde van esta
vacada este va acá y vamos a ver si en
efecto le atinamos vamos a aplicarle
comprobar respuesta muy bien vamos a ver
ahora este problema dice este triángulo
tiene medidas de 45 grados y 90 grados
me imagino que es 45 45 y 90 identifica
qué ángulo o ángulos en el triángulo
tienen cada medida esto también se ve
muy divertido claramente el ángulo en b
es el de 90 grados y los otros dos son
los de 45
muy bien le picamos comprobar respuesta
excelente una más nos preguntan cuál es
la medida de este ángulo bueno pues este
ángulo se ve bastante pequeño entonces
no puede ser obtuso de hecho es menor a
90 grados así que no es mi 135 ni 180
mil 90 de modo que debe ser de 30 grados
y en efecto es como una doceava parte de
la circunferencia y por lo tanto pues si
tiene sentido que sea de 30 grados todos
estos dibujos podemos asumir que están a
escala
muy bien